W
IS COMING.
THANK YOU.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI SAYS
SHE IS STANDING DOWN AS LEADER
OF HOUSE DEMOCRATS AND NEW
CONGRESS AFTER LEADING THE PARTY
FOR NEARLY 20 YEARS.
>> WE MUST MOVE BOLDLY INTO THE
FUTURE GROUNDED BY PRINCIPLES
THAT PROPELLED US THIS FAR AND
OPEN TO FRESH POSSIBILITIES FOR
THE FUTURE AND WITH GREAT
CONFIDENCE IN OUR CAUCUS, I WILL
NOT SEEK REELECTION TO
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IN THE
NEXT CONGRESS.
FOR ME THE HOUR HAS COME FOR A
NEW GENERATION.
>> Todd: "FOX AND FRIENDS FIRST"
CO-HOST BRIAN KILMEADE JOINS US,
WHETHER IT IS HAKEEM JEFFRIES OR
SOMEONE ELSE HOW DOES LEADERSHIP
CHANGE WITHOUT NANCY PELOSI AT
THE HELM.
>> Brian: FIRST OF ALL, I DO NOT
FEEL GUILTY NOT BEING IN
BUFFALO.
MORE ON THAT LATER, MIGHT DO A
STENT ON THE WEATHER CHANNEL, I
EMBRACED IT.
19 YEARS TWO FOUR-YEAR TERMS,
SHE DID A LOT FOR HER AND IF YOU
THINK OBAMACARE IS GREAT, YOU
ARE HAPPY, GREAT IDEA TO RIP UP
THE STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS,
THRILLED, I THOUGHT THAT WAS ONE
OF THE MOST HORRIFIC THINGS, SHE
WAS CHEERED AND SHOULD HAVE BEEN
RIPPED.
82 YEARS OLD, DOING SOMETHING
BENEVOLENT, YOU BASICALLY HAVE
NO CHOICE AND HOYER ALL RIGHT, I
WILL MOVE, TOO.
HAKEEM JEFFRIES IS TALENTED, BUT
POLARIZING.
>> Carley: PROGRESSIVE,
REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING COULD THE
DEVIL BE BETTER THAN THE DEVIL
YOU DENT?
>> Brian: HE HAS A LOT OF
ENERGY, IS NANCY PELOSI PROUD OF
WHAT SHE LEFT IN SAN FRANCISCO?
NOBODY WATCHED DECLINE IN A CITY
MORE FRONT AND CENTER THAN WE'VE
SEEN, THEY GIVE THE SMACK AND
GRAB, USED TO BE THE PLACE OF
TROLLEY CARS.
BASICALLY PEOPLE ARE SCARED TO
GO TO A GIANTS GAME.
>> Carley: GREAT POINT.
>> Todd: SOMETHING WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY IS TIKTOK STILL A THINK,
WRAY SHARING CONCERN OVER DATA
AND ONE THING HE FOCUSED ON WAS
TIKTOK.
LISTEN TO THIS SOUND.
>> THE GREATEST LONG-TERM THREAT
TO OUR NATION'S IDEAS,
INNOVATION AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY, NATIONAL SECURITY IS
THAT FROM CHINA AND THEY HAVE
STOLEN MORE OF AMERICAN'S
PERSONAL AND BUSINESS DATA THAN
EVERY OTHER NATION COMBINED.
>> Todd: WENT ON TO SAY THEIR
MAIN CONCERN IS TIKTOK.
BRIAN, WHY HADN'T THIS BEEN
BANNED?
HEAD OF FTC SAYS IT SHOULD BE
BANNED.
>> Brian: IT IS SO POPULAR, BOTH
MY DAUGHTERS CAME UP TO ME AND
SAID CAN I SPEAK TO YOU, CAN YOU
FIND OUT FROM WORK, IS TIKTOK
GOING TO BE BANNED?
INSTAGRAM, SNAPCHAT, WE COULD
OUT INNOVATE CHINA.
NANCY PELOSI IS ON THE SAME
PAGE, CHINA IS THE PROBLEM AND
CHALLENGE.
EVERY ASPECT FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION TO THE
BIDEN FARMLAND TO BUYING LAND TO
WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH
HACKING, WE AGREE THAT IS THE
PROBLEM, THERE HAS TO BE
PRESSURE ON CORPORATE AMERICA.
THAT COULD BE UNIFYING FUNCTION
AND NUMBER ONE ISSUE AND ONLY
THING CHRIS WRAY COULD ANSWER
WAS THAT.
COMING UP ON "FOX AND FRIENDS"
IS ENES KANTER WILL BE WITH US,
WE'LL REVIEW WHAT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT AND GO OVER ONE MAIN THING
HAPPENING TODAY AND THAT IS
HUNTER BIDEN, CLEAR FROM THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THEY ARE GOING
TO FOCUS ON THAT RIGHT AWAY.
RETORT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
ABOUT THE HUNTER BIDEN
INVESTIGATION IS LAME, THAT
MEANS DON'T LOOK AT IT, THEY
DON'T HAVE A BIG STORY, SATURDAY
AT 8:00 ON ONE NATION, SOMETHING
TODD WAS GOING TO GET TO, WE'LL
PREVIEW THE WORLD CUP, PEOPLE
ARE UPSET, IT IS SUCH A CRAZY
PLACE TO HAVE A SOCCER VENUE,
THEY ARE HIRING ACTORS TO
PRETEND THEY ARE SOCCER FANS
BECAUSE NOBODY IS SHOWING UP,
AND MIGRANTS BUILDING WERE
ALLOWED TO PRACTICE WITH THE
PLAYERS.
>> Todd: YOU HAVE A HUGE DAY
AHEAD OF YOU --
>> Carley: YOU ARE DOING EVERY
SHOW UNTIL LAURA INGRAHAM LAURA
INGRAHAM, UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Brian: HARD THING IS
STRIPPING THIS PLACE DOWN, OUR
GREAT STAFF WILL BE DOING THAT.
>> Carley: AS WE STRIP THIS
PLACE DOWN, YOU SHOULD TELL
PEOPLE WHAT TO DO, GET DRESSED.
>> Brian: YOU HAVE 19 MINUTES,
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO